[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive time then to
see what is making the headlines with
andrew pearce consultant editor of the
daily mail and kevin mcguire associate
editor of the daily mirror both with us
from now until just before midnight
so front pages let's start with the
telegraph it leads with the breaking
news tonight that britain is to send
channel migrants to rwanda to have their
asylum claims processed
the express also with that story calling
it a bold plan
while the daily mail says the idea is to
smash the people smuggling gangs preying
on the migrants trying to get to britain
the metro leads with the resignation of
the justice minister lord wolfson over
boris johnson's refusal to resign after
being fined for attending illegal
downing street parties during lockdown
well the guardian says mr johnson could
face three more fines over events that
he is alleged to have attended same
story fought the mirror which claims it
as an exclusive with the headline worst
is yet to come that's the mail isn't it
the financial times says the potential
threat from neighboring russia has
pushed finland and sweden closer to
joining nato
quick reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's uh go straight to our guests
then andrew pearce from the mail and
kevin mcguire from the mirror welcome to
both of you um so let's go to that
breaking news then uh daily telegraph
amongst the newspapers leading andrew
with this idea of sending channel
migrants to rwanda for what the
government is calling processing your
thoughts
well this has been a long time coming
there's been a number of uh foreign
locations floated albania was one option
rwanda's been around for a while it
appears that pretty patera who's been
getting a lot of flack from her own side
from a lot of people
over the apparent inability to be able
to stem the flow of illegal migrant
crossings in the channel has now struck
a deal with rwanda uh we won't be the
first country in europe to do that
denmark has already done it uh very few
house of protests from denmark there
will be howls of protest here of course
not least from kevin mcguire uh but this
could
be the way to smash
the evil people smugglers because people
are continuing to cross the channel they
they allude to britain because they
think they'll never get sent back
they're probably right because the the
migrant system is in such chaos but if
they think they're then going to be
taken straight to rwanda four and a half
thousand miles away they may think twice
before risking their families on these
crossings and the view of the government
is and i share it that a lot of these
people who cross the channel are young
men with money in their pocket which is
why they can afford to pay the people
smugglers who then
come to britain to look for jobs they
could apply the proper way but instead
they cross the channel and it's causing
huge huge problems in many communities
particularly if you live in dover and
some of those channel areas because of
the sheer numbers of people involved and
it's also anna incredibly expensive
hotel accommodation hostile
accommodation
this won't be cheap either but if it
deters people from coming it might be a
lot cheaper than the current system and
some of them have fled also from places
like syria and after seeing what the
russians are doing in ukraine perhaps
people have a bit more sympathy for them
that's the the difficulty isn't it so
what are you saying then this this is
just a deterrent is it kevin is that the
idea of this
no i think it's just a blow a big racist
uh whistle isn't it and turn people
against migrants the fear of the unknown
there we are we got the government
running a deeply flawed hostile system
on ukrainian refugees who've struggled
to get
visas and now one of their pet projects
is to offshore people to show it they're
being tough and the house of anger won't
just be
from me it'll be from people like david
davis uh conservative and people my
cabinet minister who thinks it's
absolutely cruel and will be hugely
expensive too are you really going to
send people who've been sex trafficked
children people victims of torture
people fleeing terror or 5000 miles to
rwanda if the home secretary is framing
it as beating the people traffickers
that's quite interesting so will that
only be people who have paid uh and have
come with a people trafficker so if you
jump in the back of the lorry as uh post
covered
brexit bureaucracy to some extent trade
reopens uh lorries are crossing the the
channel if appeal or ferry's ever run
again uh are they gonna be exempt or
people on planes or people who overstay
their welcome i think it's a it's a
really really dreadful system this it
sends out completely the wrong message
to the rest of the world about britain
it's not it's not civilized and has been
a lot of criticism and i think a more
limited scheme in
denmark and andrew will probably say
well look uh australia has a system
sending people i think is papua new
guinea
the camps they send them to in papua new
guinea one they're hugely expensive and
two there is uh violence and sexual
violence is absolutely rampant and
what's proved successful in australia
which of course is a huge landmass
quite a distance from any other land
masses is turning boats away but they're
big boats they turn away they're not the
small dinghies that if you tried to push
back remember pretty patel's plan on
that you would capsize them in the
channel we've had plans for solid booms
giant waves and this this is a latest
part there'll be a lot of opposition
within the conservative party on this
the the decent concertos will see how
deeply flawed and inhuman it is well the
daily express calls it a bold plan uh
the prime minister will make a statement
tomorrow uh suggesting that yet another
600 migrants made the trip
yesterday your paper andrew the daily
mail
calls it a dramatic migrant blueprint
suggesting that it will cost 120 million
pounds to british taxpayers initially
and it's a five-year agreement also
suggesting it is a world first deal with
the east african nation to host these
migrants what happens to them
subsequently who knows but you know will
this get support from people has the
ukrainian crisis and in a sense the
slowness of our response bringing
refugees from there here has that
changed britain's attitude to helping
people from abroad who are facing their
own personal crises
well i actually think a lot of people
are sick to death of what's happening on
the channel i think if you look at voter
concerns focus groups they find it
really frustrating
they're effectively illegal crossings uh
we know that people have died crossing
two
and these people are leaving france
which is a very civilized country it's a
member of the european union where they
can be quite safe quite civilized so
what are they running away from in
france uh some of them will be genuine
asylum speakers
are you going to let me answer the
question or not
anna yep can i speak yeah no no please
please thanks very much as i was saying
some of them will be genuine asylum
seekers i'm sure uh and but but the but
what's happening at the moment is
thousands of these people are coming
into britain and they are being put in
a
poor hotel accommodation or hostels and
then they disappear very few of them are
ever sent back there's very little
evidence many of them are asylum seekers
majority
a lot of them are seen as economic
migrants with their very expensive
phones and many of them are under the
age of 30. they're coming to britain
because they think it's the land of milk
and honey and they know when they get
here and almost certainly not be sent
back and it's telling the government did
something about it
the refugee council uh
who surveyed them about half of them are
legit legitimate claims absolutely clear
others others may those may be contested
andrew said at the beginning they
haven't applied properly there is no
proper way to apply instead of all this
global britain talk after brexit thought
was britain as being erected to keep
people out we saw that with ukrainian
refugees when
pretty patel said oh there's been a
surge of people going off to to cali at
home office officials to help i think
there were two two people there handing
out bottles of
of water as people were told to go to
brussels or paris where no appointments
were available i've looked at the case
of three ukrainian refugees trying to
get into the uk who had a british link
they had a family to stay with because
they had a british system going to take
them over of ukrainian heritage and they
got a complete terrible rule around they
might they might have finally batted
down the hormones but it's taken them
some time so if you try and lock people
out and you don't give them any
legitimate way in when they have
legitimate claims to come here under the
the united nations convention on
refugees now there was a european system
when we were part of the european union
which was the
european union so that doesn't apply now
but a refugee who is fleeing just say
syria iraq iran eritrea any of these
really troubled areas is entitled in
international law to try and come to the
uk
hugely to our country yeah right but
kevin goes on about the system we had
when we're in the eu it didn't work then
because they were coming in in the back
of lorries in their hundreds they were
coming through the channel tunnel in the
hundreds they weren't using the proper
system kevin
and then when and then when the channel
was kevin let me finish when the channel
tunnel option was closed to them they
started crossing the channel it didn't
work so maybe this system will work
okay well this is a this is a hugely
controversial area we will talk more i
know a little bit later on for now stay
there lots more still to discuss uh
including the ramifications of partygate
the resignation today uh and this story
as well uh the idea that finland and
sweden might join nato back in a moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now andrew pearce consultant editor
of the daily mail and kevin mcguire
associate editor of the daily mirror
welcome back to both of you
let's go to the metro in the guardian
kevin shall we
the metro leading on the resignation
today of lord wolfson justice minister
after the breaking of the lockdown rules
and the guardian suggesting that boss
johnson himself may face three more
fines uh which would have what impact do
you think
yeah well that'll be the question will
it be accumulative and just build up the
pressure or will each successive uh fine
if there's three more which that my own
paper the mirror is also reporting
because of the likely will people just
shrug and say that's another fine and
they have less impact that's going to be
the big political battle on where it it
goes because the promise has certainly
taken a political hit and lord wilson
isn't particularly well known it's got
to be said as a verse to resign but he
was a justice minister and i think as he
makes clear it's the level of
criminality in downing street and also
the official response which is just to
shrug shoulders in one way say oh in all
humility i didn't do very very much but
if the rule of law counts for anything
lawmakers should not be lawbreakers
just trying to get the mirror up
actually but we will we will hopefully
see it soon um but let's move to the ft
shall we uh which is one of the many
implications of the russian ukrainian
war which is the idea that finland and
sweden
might imminently actually very soon join
nato which would be an extraordinary
development wouldn't it
it really would and anna this is exactly
what putin
set out not to have peter wants to
weaken the strength and influence of
nato but because of his illegal
uh invasion of ukraine uh it spooked
both finland and sweden who've been
thinking about joining for a very long
time they're quite close their borders
are quite close it will change the
geography and the security
infrastructure of the whole region
russia will huff and puff and bluster
and not like it but it will make nato
even stronger and i for one hope they
get get they join and because it's
pretty clear ukraine are not going to
join uh that will be all part of the
eventual settlement i'm sure with putin
but it seems sweden and finland will and
that's scandinavia putting their money
behind nato and the uh and against putin
yeah very interesting indeed uh both of
you thank you very much need andrew
pearce kevin mcguire thank you